[Music]
italy was europe's first
epicenter for the coronavirus outbreak
but now it's starting to reopen
venice one of the world's most famous
cities has suffered
without its usual tourists but it's
enjoyed an unintended benefit
chris livesay traveled to the city of
water to see how nature
is suddenly flourishing good morning
now as hard as the lockdown has been on
all of us there's one
silver lining no one can deny staying at
home has been largely good for the
environment
and here in venice this lagoon city has
returned to its pre-industrial
tranquility
venice perhaps more than any other city
under lockdown
has gone from one extreme to the other
the rialto bridge the grand canal even
saint mark's square
deserted streets and canals usually
awash with tourists
now so still nature is filling the void
says ecologist marco siegovini
look at that oh my gosh yeah there he is
under the ropes
oh my gosh with babies nearby an octopus
beneath a dock
schools of fish and underwater life and
jellyfish like the one we spotted
hardly any boats to scare them away or
to churn up cloudy sediment
the transformation so dramatic the
european space agency snapped these
satellite images
taken one year apart conspicuously
absent
cruise ships last year more than 600
passed through
their titanic size splashing corrosive
wake on these fragile foundations
says environmental scientist jane
demasto what is going on with these
steps they look like they're about to
fall in the water
they probably are about to fall in the
water
once last year the damage was not so
gradual four people were injured when
this cruise liner slammed into a
venetian dock
but today it's more like a a lake
and i just imagine that all the
buildings in venice are kind of
singing to each other and they must be
so relieved not to be
so bashed around without the ship's
billowing exhaust her team has also
measured a marked improvement
in air quality though not without a cost
empty bridges empty canals but also
empty pockets
without tourists covet 19 has left the
economy here
gasping for air this fishmonger says
he'll go bankrupt selling to venetians
alone
there's only 50 000 of them compared to
30 million tourists
who used to come every year something
you can see clearly at night
when the few lights on are of the few
people who live here
the many homes with lights off of the
many tourists now gone
how bad the mayor is desperate for them
to come back
we're not dying of coronavirus he tells
business leaders at this demonstration
we're dying of hunger and it's striking
that
delicate balance between the ecology and
the economy that's going to determine
the future
of venice for now it seems like there's
a tension between public health
and public wealth here and around the
world
chris lipsey cbs news venice
such a beautiful city and it's lovely to
see it empty
gail but it as chris said it can't
survive that way
yeah look at the human beings mucking
everything up i hope they can find a
balance between
the economy and the ecology i hope they
can work that on
and anthony perfect time to notice your
painting behind you because i know it's
from venice
it's of venice it's up venice people ask
me i get a lot of requests
st mark square i get a lot of requests
from people that say do you think
anthony will ever sell that painting
what's the answer anthony mason
nope okay okay just wanted on record
that's what i said but i don't want to
speak for you